you probably know Luigi as the most
famous sidekick in gaming history a
second fiddle the guy who's always
destined to be player to the weak you
spend so much time in his older brothers
shadow it's easy to forget that he's a
fully fledged character on his own and
depending on the media he's appearing in
not a particularly nice one here's a
look at the most terrible things Luigi
has ever done just in it for the cash in
1986 Nintendo and Grouper Studios
released an hour-long anime produced to
promote the Japanese release of Super
Mario Brothers 2 later known to American
gamers as The Lost Levels
while the film is a reasonably faithful
adaptation of the first couple Mario
games there's one big difference in the
film Luigi is the absolute worst and
we're not just talking about his
bizarrely miss coloured costume while
Mario's motives are noble Luigi only
agrees to join him on the quest after
being promised all the gold coins they
find on the adventure as a result he
spends the whole cartoon greedily
searching for gold even at the risk of
his friends lives this version of Luigi
isn't just greedy either
while tripping on mushrooms he punches
Mario in the face and when the group
runs low on food
Luigi even thinks about eating
kibi-dango the Mario Brothers doglike
companion yikes dude mad with power over
in Germany gamers were treated to Club
Nintendo a magazine filled with
absolutely insane comic strips one of
the most jarring is Super Mario in the
flesh of speed where Luigi becomes a cop
and uses his newfound authority to make
Mario's life a living hell
first he pulls Mario over for going too
fast
apparently when he's riding Yoshi down
the city street Mario needs to obey all
the regular traffic laws next Luigi
scolds Mario for referring to him as
Luigi and not officer Luigi as befits
his new position
finally when Mario hops off Yoshi's
backed by spin jumping which let's
remember is the only way to dismount the
dinosaur in Super Mario World
Luigi informs his brother that spin
jumps are strictly prohibited between
1:00 and 3:00 p.m. and while Luigi's a
stickler for the rules he's not corrupt
he finds Mario his own brother
sixty coins for his transgression that's
right family means nothing and officer
Luigi's totalitarian dystopia all talk
in Paper Mario the thousand-year door
Luigi is revealed to be a lying blowhard
as it turns out all the supposed
adventures he boasts about throughout
the game or complete fiction
for example Luigi says that in order to
defeat a monster
Luigi through the squid-like blooper
named bluey at the boss's weak spot
according to bluey that's true but Luigi
conveniently leaves out the part where
he missed sending bluey flying into a
puddle of lava even worse the general
public actually buys his propaganda as
books based on Luigi's adventures begin
appearing in the game so given how
little credit he gets for his real
adventures it's hard to blame him
totally uninhibited in Super Paper Mario
Luigi isn't just comic relief he's also
the game's main villain according to the
dark prognostic Asst a book of
prophecies written by an unknown author
the man in green is the perfect host for
the chaos heart which will destroy the
world that man in green is of course
Luigi after being captured by the master
hypnotist at Ostia Luigi's that abyssion
czar released and he becomes the
sinister mr. el openly jealous of
Mario's abilities mr. el teams up with a
new robot buddy and spins the game
attacking Mario he even makes a move on
Princess Peach
[Music]
and that's even before the mercenary
dimaggio fuses with Luigi and tries to
bring about the end of the world using
the chaos heart so was it all
mind-control or did the bad guys just
unleash Luigi's true feelings all we can
say for sure is
watch your back Mario fraternal abuse
most of the time
Luigi's love-hate relationship with his
brother ends up coming across as
passive-aggressive but in Mario and
Luigi bowser's Inside Story
there's nothing passive about it early
in the game both brothers get hammers
which they can use in combat and assault
puzzles while Mario uses his hammer in
reasonable ways like destroying
obstacles to block his path
Luigi uses his to beat on his older
brother pummeling Mario is the only way
to proceed in the game but you better
believe it hurts one of the main reasons
to use Luigi's hammer is to transform
Mario into mini Mario you know before
Mario takes when he's damaged by an
enemy leaving him unable to break bricks
and teetering on the brink of death but
hey it also allows Mario to pass through
small passages so why not gamble with
your brother's life looks like Luigi is
working out some serious issues here
tellingly Luigi doesn't even flinch when
he learns he has to hit Mario on the
head that's not a loving brother not the
cold-hearted minutes thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]
you